if you were here last Sunday we had a
very fun class and we talked about
obscure openings we discussed four
different openings who was here from
last Sunday raise your hands okay quite
a few people here which openings did we
cover last Sunday because today is
obscure openings number two continuation
okay of that font topic what do we cover
last week opening one Baltic opening
opening - huh all been correct opening
three - was opening for the we covered
this opening remember d 4e 5 we covers
this opening in this is called England
England in England I actually also
thought it was English but it's England
you know then I look it up and it's
England gambit okay and the last one the
the fun one we had is d4
f5 in that is called - defense
absolutely it's actually not a
considered a very good opening but
incredibly popular in fact it was played
right after the lecture next few days
there were two world class games one
played by world champion played against
polish grandmaster moy taschek world
champion lost Marcus Carson lost playing
this and also we had Caruana
playing the dutch again and also losing
to the same guy so it was not a very
good result against the Dutch so in
those so that's the Dutch defense okay
very good
but we already reviewed this openings
and now we are going to continue okay
now with the next openings that we have
okay so the next opening I have here
it's this one night
six c4 and c5 okay this is not a sub
school but still you don't see it
happening too often here okay so now
when you play e5 here what is the name
of this opening we have a big class here
this is very big class so please make
sure you're raising your hands okay so
when you're answering the question so
after he plays d5 what's the name of
this opening anybody it's when they give
you a pawn that is called what that term
when they give you a pawn what is it
called
yes gambit correct
that's a gambit and they're doing the
gambit but the question is what's the
name of this gambit here okay I guess
I'll tell you the name of this one but
make sure you remember okay this is
called budapest gambit okay
budapest it's not there are a lot of
games play with this with this okay so
it was I guess inventing in the city of
Budapest in Hungary
okay so Budapest gambit so when they
give you a pawn block gives you a part
normally playing a gambit you accept it
okay if you are plot if you're white and
they give you a pawn you accept a gambit
we take it okay now no what if we define
it we could decline it but then that
means we're not playing for the maximum
advantage okay because you're white they
give you your pawn you should accept
upon and you know go for the
complications but you'll have a pawn
because that extra pawn could help you
to win a game later on okay so remember
again everybody if you're white they're
playing a gambit what do we do we accept
the gambit we don't back up from the
gambit okay because if you back up from
the gamete that means you
not playing the for the maximum
advantage you're trying to get of course
you should be familiar with it if you're
not familiar with it maybe it's okay to
back up and do something else but if you
familiar with did you go for the gambit
94 now they're trying to win the pawn
back here and now you have to play a
good move here Bishop f4 protecting the
e5 pawn okay II five pound now is
protected you have to play this book
there other possibilities here as well
but Bishop f4 is the best question you
can it's just a different line here you
can play Knight f3 but the problem with
it is
he plays Bishop c5 and now attacking on
f2 and you forced to play e3 and after
you play it three now you're your Bishop
is trapped you cannot move the bishop
okay so we get the bishop out first so
we're not trapped okay now I place 96
attacking only five question could play
g5 but that's very risky very risky
you could Knight f3 pay close attention
because I'll be testing you after this
okay to make sure you remember it so now
he plays Bishop before check now your
King is under check here now what you're
going to do here you got a couple of
options here but what you're going to do
we need to block the check here but
where where should we go here yes yeah
now bd2 okay Knight c3 is another
alternative but I like 92 more now black
plays Queen e7 there is a very difficult
there is a very tricky trap here okay so
I will show you so make sure your fall
for this trap because if you fall for it
you'll get made it so you need to play
the move III here okay you need to play
the move III here very important but if
you play the move a tree now you can
potentially walk into this trap Knight
takes e5 Knight takes e5 Knight takes e5
pawn takes Bishop and now 93 check may
because you cannot take it it's a
checkmate you can call that smother may
- yeah it's a little bit different
concept here so take a good look at this
trap okay make sure you don't fall for
it you know I'll be happy to see you win
games like this but don't be on the
other side here and get checkmated okay
so you don't play the move a three here
you play III okay
Knight takes e5 okay Knight takes e5
he's getting the palma don't be too
attached to that pump it's okay to lose
the pawn don't be too attached okay to
it
now we take he takes we just develop we
just continue developing our pieces okay
he castles we castle now this actually
this dis opening played at a world
championship level
I mean Nigel anatoly karpov Nigel short
1994 they had this position so this is
irregular opening but even got to the
point where played in that in that level
so now here white to play can you find a
move that will create some problems for
this Bishop in a sense that it will be
difficult for him to move the bishop
what do you think what move can you play
here to create some problems for that
Knight create problems for the black
bishop yes mmm this is a little problem
you're leaving your piece unguarded okay
be careful be careful of leaving any
pieces unguarded I'll take it I want to
trap that bishop or do something to the
bishop so it cannot go anywhere what can
we do to the bishop yes
you could do that yeah that's before
they used to play a 3 here Bishop take
z2 but better Anatoly Karpov came up
with something better here by the way
who is Anatoly Karpov is that name
familiar to you ok let's wait first tell
me who is Anatoly Karpov and why I
mention his name is he a good player yes
absolutely it was a world champion one
of the strongest placed slow strongest
players ever in us a very strong player
very good player and very positional
player not so much tactically but
positionally and here we see how he
demonstrates it so what is the move here
to do something with this Bishop here
yes correct
you just play like Anatoly Karpov
correct now the point of this move is
now you are ready to play a tree and
attack the bishop and the bishop it's
not going to have so sort of he's going
to regret now that he didn't take the
knight early on because now what is he
going to do so now he plays the move b6
continue now what you're going to do now
yes upon 8/3 absolutely if the bishop
goes on the rim you just take and look
at those weaknesses we can assist okay
so it goes Bishop to c5 and now Bishop
goes on c5 now yes
no Queen to d5 runs into [ __ ] p6 we
need something better here that Bishop
is still strong here that Bishop is
still strong what do we do
take it correct now it's got two options
to capture back one of them is just
losing on the spot he should take back
with a pawn we'll discuss that d takes
e5 why is this move losing can you find
a move that will basically win a piece
eh a strong move here that winning a
piece your idea should be winning a
piece here
okay many hands here I see okay
what's the move yeah but then he just
takes that looks like just an exchange
we need something better now can you
find a weak piece here that is not
protected there and then put pressure on
it you find a piece and put pressure on
it
okay so let's see in the back Queen d5
correct now what do we call this in
chess this move has a term that we had
need to use is good for you to know the
term here what what is this move doing
now
what is it doing yes double attack fork
or double attack when you're attacking
two pieces at the same time that is
called fork also double attack okay this
will be winning a piece immediately
because there's no way to protect both
pieces so he takes back with a pawn and
now now what is the idea
Karpov played b4 and basically at this
point you know it's pretty clear that
white has a nice advantage because he
has two bishops and black pawn structure
it's not very good and carpel went on to
win the game and also went on to win the
match decisively so we do not see any
more budapest gambit than that it's at
very very high level games okay for the
World title
okay so we're going to go back here and
make sure one more move 97 Bishop g4
this was the game of Karpov okay now
we're going to go back and review this
opening and make sure you all remember
it now okay
ready to and you can get this exact
position here that's what we're trying
to do here question white one Anatoly
Karpov one okay but we're not going to
look at the whole game we are learning
the opening so we can learn another
opening besides the Budapest and then
you're going to have some time to
practice it today okay
okay we are ready to you you want to say
the move or you have a question first of
all go ahead correct raise your hand if
you remember the moves second move
'if I've name of this gambit which
gambit is a playing yes
Budapest gambit Budapest gambit okay now
when they do a gambit you're white they
do a gambit what are you supposed to do
what is supposed to do absolutely accept
it don't be afraid and back up accept a
gambit and play confidently okay that's
why I'm showing you how to refute this
gambit here 94 now your pawn is under
attack see and if you know this opening
you're going to play Knight f3 because
that looks like the most common move
here and then you have your Bishop a
little bit blocked in and you may not
feel very very comfortable but something
better you have something better here
what can you do here remember we're not
playing Knight f3 we're doing something
better
correct excellent 96 attacking the pawn
next move now he is still trying you you
you're not going to be too attached to
the pawn but at the same time you don't
want to give the pawn too easily you do
your moves you get your development next
move for white you want to get your
development okay yes yes more
confidently correct check now he gives
you a check now what do we do now we
have a couple of ways to block it how do
we do it
Knight BD - you got two nice to go -
you're gonna IBD - now goes Queen d7 now
the pawn is under attack here now again
don't try to chase you never play this
a3 move okay don't chase it never play
it what do we do III correct
he takes it next
now we're a little bit behind here yeah
we don't want to be behind here we want
to catch up we want to catch up castle
say he went to safety what about us
he went to safety what we should do
absolutely care so we go to safety as
well now he goes d6 and this is a move
that he might regret now because now his
bishop is going to be a little bit in
problem here but to take advantage of it
you have to play the correct move yes
excellent move exclamation mark
now b6 continue what's the next move
you cannot relax you have to continue
play correctly here if you want to have
an advantage otherwise no advantage yes
attacking the bishop correct Bishop c5
remember bishop is a strong piece when
we have a chance yes uh-huh
capture it he has to take back with the
b-pawn because if it takes with the
b-pawn why is this move losing why is
this move losing here huh yes
how ok well he can't possibly lose a
rope he probably is going to avoid that
by moving the rook or a bishop but then
he loses a piece he is losing a piece
actually ok all right
Queen d5 and what is this term call
again everybody or for
tack or fork double attack or fork
remember that it's a very strong
tactical idea because usually when you
do this it's very difficult for him to
defend against this both threats okay if
you even set up some positions you
attack to pieces it's very difficult to
defend those pieces okay because
difficult to defend them at the same
time so he takes back BC now continue
now we need to heat we need to create
some pawn structure weaknesses not yet
not not 25 before then if it takes he
takes you we take back and he also has
weakness on a7 okay weakness on a7 and
you know then after c5 another weakness
he will have here
so he goes ninety seven and now what is
the correct move here the final move of
our review
what did Karpov play here to get that
advantage
what did Karpov play here huh absolutely
so remember this position played in 1994
Anatoly Karpov against Nigel short okay
very famous game and yeah we didn't yeah
and then white white won the game it was
not easy it was a long game and in the
long an endgame white one but but as far
as the opening this is how you want to
get advantage against Budapest gambit
next opening okay d4 Knight f6 c4 c5 now
when they play this move if they ask you
a question what is the name of this
opening what do you say here do we have
a clear name here for the opening at the
moment what do you say let's say no you
say unknown we don't know yet we don't
know here don't say no yet because it
will be some opening so the trick is we
don't know the name of the opening
because there could be several different
openings we don't know yet we need to
wait for the third move for black okay
so you must play d5 here and there are
two different openings here they can
play each six we're not going to cover
the e6
what is the name of this opening anybody
yes
benoni defense but we're covering the
gambits today and we get a cover the
move b5 and what is the name of this
opening this opening has two names can
you name them both the two names this
opening has been called gambit correct
but it has another name it's called
Volga gambit okay
you referred also Volga gambit okay so
so let's say Benko gambit that's the
name of the Bangko gambit and we already
know if they do a gambit against us and
we are white what do we do we accept the
gambit so you take I will show you how
to get a good position against this
gambit a6 now
basically they sacrifice a pawn they try
to get some activities so it take
Bishop takes Knight c3 you develop you
have a question yes you could but that's
helping us develop our pieces and we
develop so d6 watch carefully what I'm
showing you here efore he takes don't be
afraid to lose your turn to castle there
is a way we're going to castle by hand
also known as manual Castle here so g6
nigt to Bishop g7 h3 Castle now how we
can try to castle here by hand so we
have our rook into the game here can you
do that
manual castling here how yes
perfect that's fine that's fine we don't
want to do anything yet this is good so
King H that's why you play h3 to get a
little square for the King and then you
walk with the King King g1 King h2 now
he plays for example Queen a5 we develop
our queen on c2 look everyone the reason
they pay the bank or gambit because they
have pressure on a and B files that's
what they try to put a lot of pressure
on you so if they look p1 to move away
from the pressure and the next move is
you would like to play rook on d1 Bishop
g5 and white is up upon and black
doesn't have that much of an
accommodation here okay
so that's your setup here okay so let's
say rook p7 Bishop g5 rook b8 and you
can get this in look h t1 that's one
idea so you know black has different
plans here but your concept is remaining
the same
Bishop goes on g5 rook on d1 and you
have a solid position with the extra
pawn so this is how you play against the
bank or gambit so let's review and try
to reach this position here okay okay
let's go
continue
name of the opening we don't know yet
unknown we don't know yet
d5 any plays b5 now we know the opening
already after this third mode we already
clearly know the name of this opening
usually by third move we probably
already know the name of the opening
okay usually by the third move we
already know it yes Volga gambit and the
second name
that's will go is the older name and the
other one is Bengal gambit correct so we
accept the gambit by taking the pawn now
he plays a6
we still take it and now we need to
develop our pieces here Knight c3
continue yes
yes
no we're not paying g3 yes better
we have to get our pieces our Knights
they need to be protecting each other
okay you have to develop the knight so
they protect each other
specify we have two knights which night
now what is the next move creating that
escape square h3 castle and now we get a
castle by hand a manual castling okay
how are we going to do that perfect
continue continue
now we gotta get the Queen yeah Queen
has a good square now to go to here you
want to put it there on a good square
close c2 on Queen d3 you're going to get
attacked with a knife that's why now it
goes here and now he is putting pressure
like that so that Luke on a 1 is minced
place we need to put it somewhere safer
correct
and now the plan is to play what are the
next two moves here for y2 to complete
development yes
Bishop g5 and rook d1 and in some point
ultimate plan is to play F 45 to break
through and white has a very comfortable
position ok any questions regarding the
bank Banco gambit or Volga gambit ok so
we got to learn to openings to other
openings today so slowly all the
openings will be known to you so this
was which two openings who learned today
the first opening was yeah Budapest and
the second one banco gambit excellent